l'hiver bonjour gilet vert je disais que
vous étiez amis collègues en ce moment
mais que vous y étiez à personne plutôt
dans le sud de l'Ukraine qu'avez-vous
constaté qu'avez-vous pu voir sur place
il y aura aussi la question des mines
qui auraient pu être déplacés par l'eau
cela concerne peut-être plus les
villages autour d'ergson mais la ville
de que la ville de Herson même et c'est
aussi quelque chose que les autorités
doivent prendre en compte
pour quel instant les autorités des
représentants des officiels ont été
dépêchés sur place n'est-ce pas
oui il y avait le vice premier ministre
responsable de la reconstruction de
luquent cupraco va ainsi que le vice
ministre de l'infrastructure ils ont
parlé de l'opération humanitaire en
cours ils ont parlé aussi de très très
grandes investissements que le
gouvernement a déjà décidé pour établir
de nouvelles manières d'approvisionner
de grandes villes comme creverigues au
nom des villes qui dépendaient en partie
avant du réservoir de carouka qui
n'existera plus d'ici 4 jours selon la
compagnie ukrainienne qui gère les
centrales hydroélectriques ils disent
que il ne sera pas possible dans un
avenir proche de reconstruire ce barrage
alors il faut des d'ores et déjà pensé à
des solutions long terme parce que le
problème d'alimentation ouvre être un
très grand problème à travers toute
cette région ils étaient là aussi pour
mettre beaucoup d'en face sur le fait
que forcément la Russie doit être
culpable de ce qui s'est passé pour les
Ukrainiens c'est un crime de cœur il
semble tous convaincus que la Russie a
fait ça libérément par une explosion je
pense que d'après les renseignements
américains et divers autres sources
c'est la théorie qui est le plus
privilégié il est possible que cela soit
arrivé par mécar par les Russes qui ont
fait une explosion sont l'intention de
détruire complètement le barrage par
exemple parce que le barrage a été
endommagé par des tirs de Paris d'autres
depuis le début de ce conflit le début
de l'invasion à grande échelle je veux
dire le 24 février 2022 mais les
Ukrainiens veulent vraiment
mettre l'emphase et convaincre le monde
que c'est les vrais mots pas possible
que eux l'auraient fait à part le fait
que ils n'auraient pas de motivation
pour faire cela pour détruire une
centrale hydroélectrique qui était très
importante pour les infrastructures
électriques du pays déjà en difficulté
mais aussi tout simplement parce que ils
ne sont pas présents sur place c'est les
Russes qui contrôlaient le territoire où
se trouve ce barrage et selon les
experts il aurait été presque impossible
de le détruire
à distance l'explosion
toute porte à croire que l'explosion
c'était une explosion fait de explosif
qui avait été planté sur place sur le
barrage merci beaucoup Gulliver crack en
direct